- Have a seat.
- Thank you for being here.
- Y'all sharp, y'all sharp.
Why y'all look so good.
- I'm just saying we do
have a certain earthy tone
going today.
I haven't seen you since New
York and y'all know each other.
Y'all go way back.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- [Kelly] How do y'all know each other?
- We, well bumped into
each other a ton and then
I begged Karamo to come
do a podcast for me.
And it was the best episode
of the whole podcast.
- Aw, thank you brother.
I would do anything for him.
He's such a great guy.
All he does is just give, give,
give when he's not working.
- Oh my gosh well-
- That's like you.
- I do like to work a lot.
I know.
I probably need to go on your show
and you need to talk to me about that.
(Karamo laughs)
So wait, so you say that you haven't
had a cookie cutter
life, so what do you...
that means something
different for everybody
- Well, I am a talk show guest.
So like, the way I even found about my son
like I got papers on my doorstep
when he was 10 years old.
- [Kelly] You told me yeah.
- Yes, you know what I mean?
Like, there was abuse in
my household growing up.
You know, my father was
abusive to my mother.
You know, there was drug
addiction, you know.
And my son just recently came on my show.
He was a addicted to drugs.
I didn't know as a parent,
and I thought it had
skipped the generation.
So I understand what people go through
and I'm vulnerable enough
to talk about my own life so
that people know I get
what you're going through
and I can help you solve it.
'Cause I got the training
to solve it, you know?
- Well and I think too, I feel like-
(audience clapping)
If we're gonna be put to
the test and have to go
through all this stuff,
you might as well use it.
- [Karamo] Amen.
- You know what I'm saying?
And you have this
experience that is negative
and trying to make it a positive.
I think that's what you're doing.
And you hadn't started the show
yet, like whenever you came
on the show in New York,
so now you've started it.
How much do you love it?
- I love it so much,
but girl it so much work!
- It is!
It is a lot of work.
- Date?
Oh my gosh I was like,
"Woooo!"
This is a lot.
- It is a lot of work, but I feel-
- [Karamo] But it's rewarding.
- It is rewarding and I
think it's really important.
I feel like you seem to put
a lot of yourself into it.
Like you've like,
and what I say is your experience
and like you're relatable
and that's how you connect.
I like that.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Well, I mean, my only goal for this show
was to be able to help
people day in and day out.
If a guest leaves my show and doesn't feel
as if I gave them some tools to be better
or that they felt more healed,
I literally have given like
five guests my telephone number
and been like, "Hey,"
and then I make sure.
Or we've had only like a couple times
and I brought them back because like,
my goal is to heal.
I'm so tired of us as human beings
feeling in pain
and feeling like we're alone
and feeling like no one understands.
And I'm just like,
we have to be better
and someone has to give us the tools.
Like if I could go back
and restructure the
American school system,
I would do so many things different
because I think some of the things-
- One, implement mental health.
- Implement mental health,
because you see kids being bullied
feeling sad, feeling alone.
And even the most "popular
kids" have these feelings
of inadequacy and feeling
like "I'm not enough."
And it just turns into adults.
You see that,
that young boy in that clip
this is a young boy who's 24 as a parent.
And I'm like trying to stop him
from becoming a 40 year old
parent that's not doing right.
And I think like we should,
we all deserve to be
in good environments and be
around people that we love
and feel supportive,
but someone has to teach us.
- And I also think though
that society kind of-
(audience clapping)
- Yeah absolutely.
I also think too like,
don't you think they...
People tell us even from when we're kids
like, you know, you gotta be happy.
And it's like, "Well what?"
Everybody's not happy all the time.
Like and that's not,
that's not even doable.
Like you can't possibly accomplish that.
And I think it's, I
think it's more important
to teach someone that like,
no, you're not gonna
be happy all the time.
Life can be hard.
Like you gotta learn the
skill set to get through that.
- Listen I-
- To appreciate the happy
when it comes 'cause
it's not gonna be happy all the time.
And I think we do a disservice
to kids by saying like,
"Oh no, are you happy?"
"I want you to be happy."
And it's just like happy, happy, happy.
And it's like,
you don't have to be happy all the time.
- [Karamo] Yeah.
- It's okay.
- You know I wrote a book with my son
called "I'm Okay To Feel."
And literally the book is
about just exactly that.
Telling kids it is okay to feel
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Instead of that narrative
of being happy, happy, happy.
Consistently, consistently.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it has worked.
Like I go in these schools
and we do these readings
and kids will come up and be like,
"For the first time, like I'm okay.
"Like you're telling me I can say
that I'm sad, or I'm mad today,
And I'm not gonna get in trouble?"
Because sometimes I feel
like if someone says that,
they feel like they're being punished
and then we become
adults and we close off.
- [Kelly] Or there's
something wrong with them.
- Something wrong with them.
That's not, you know what I mean?
That's not okay.
Especially as black, young black boys,
I don't know how you grew up
but it was like, you don't talk about it.
- Go do it.
- [Karamo] Go do it.
- What's the problem? Go do it.
- What's the problem?
And I'm like,
the problem is I don't feel like it today.
Can you listen to my feelings?
You know what I mean?
And so, but-
- I love this thing with
my three-year-old daughter
and she comes home from preschool
and she tells you her color.
That's her feeling of the day.
So they've equated like
a feeling to a color.
- [Kelly] Oh, my kid does-
- So she'll come home and she'll be like,
"I'm yellow today Daddy."
(Karamo and Kelly laugh)
- And I'm like
"So where's the book with the colors?"
"What does yellow mean?"
"How do I do yellow today?"
- Oh my god,
so my daughter going to
bed last night just was
throwing a tantrum and I,
whatever for, I'm sure it mattered
but like, it didn't,
it was like something,
it was just something dumb.
She didn't wanna sleep by herself.
Whatever.
One of her friends gets to
sleep with her mom all the time.
And I'm like, "You're not
in my bed on the time."
- Yeah, not happening.
- So build a bridge.
And anyway, so I told her, I was like all,
you know, all therapy about it.
I was like,
"Oh my gosh, you know what?
I want you to feel this,
you're sad about it,
and you can cry about it,
but like, I'm gonna go."
- Yes, I'm gonna go.
- [Kelly] Like I'm going.
- Yes.
- And you are allowed to
sit here in your feelings.
- [Karamo] Yes, be in it!
- You were allowed to feel yellow.
- Yes.
- I'm going to feel green
and I'm going to go.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm gonna tell you something.
- [Kelly] Go for it.
- You did good.
- Okay.
- Because what you did is you actually
also modeled a healthy boundary.
So you, Mama Kelly you did it good!
Listen, you did it good!
- Wait, wait.
- Not only did he say,
You're allowed to feel
what you want to feel,
take the time you need,"
but then you were like,
Take your boundary girl.
Good job mama.
Listen, I don't think we encouraged
to say a good job to
our moms all the time.
- You have no idea how hard
I've been working on boundaries.
- You did good! You did good!
- I was like, thank you.
I'm gonna celebrate tonight with a drink.